this is huge it's just one hall and most
people I guess are still waiting for
registration yeah but definitely the
size of these things is ginormous
so tutorials have just started I'll be
go finding a place hi so um I just
wanted to give a little update on a
tutorial that I liked which was the
population-based search and open-ended
learning tutorial which happened on
Monday here as I was pleasantly
surprised by this tutorial because I
knew almost nothing about these
techniques and they seem really cool
seems to be a really cool line of
research so started out with what is
population-based search and basically in
population-based search you don't want
to just reach one solution of a problem
but you want to kind of maintain a
population of solutions that you develop
over time
so um natural evolution would be an
example of that so this this can have
many benefits that will kind of that
were explored in the tutorial so the
kind of culprit of traditional
optimization let's say you have a
classification problem you just train
one classifier on it is what they call
deception meaning that okay a better
example is an RL problem where you need
to reach some goal but since the goal
might be very hard to reach your
algorithm has basically nothing to go on
sis there's no stepping stones so
usually people go and construct a reward
function in a very clever way but this
this can be overcome with these
techniques as well so just imagine like
the hardest video game in the Atari
suite this would be something like
Montezuma's Revenge where you first need
to collect some key and then go to some
door and only then you get a score right
so this reward function is too ambitious
and
would lead is a problem they call your
deception an observation they make is if
you look at nature and natural evolution
it is very successful even without a
goal so there's no goal in mind to
natural evolution except reproduction
creates other reproduction but it's not
a goal that's that's simply a kind of
underlying mechanic mechanism and if you
look at nature all this variety of life
was produced without a goal in mind and
all this variety of life filling
different niches and basically
reproducing their own at their own pace
and so it's a very interesting
observation that the goal of this entire
field is kind of to model to go into the
this direction of what if we don't
really go after only the cost function
but what if we so in the most extreme
case what if we build a search algorithm
that only wants to create novel things
so we're kind of novelty is the only
goal what happens then and it turns out
some some interesting things can be
achieved with that so they introduced
this notion of quality diversity which
basically means if if you look at let's
again take life on earth you want all
the achievable behaviors that there are
so maybe one achievable behavior is a
very fast life form that can hunt other
life-forms and another achievable
behavior is one that camouflage is very
well and so on and you want to kind of
find for each of these behaviors you
want to find the best possible example
so that's the direction that these
algorithms go into and an algorithm that
they present it was map elites so n AP
elites which goes as follows so let's
say you have a bunch of dimensions you
care about say how fast the creature is
how tall it is how
well it is camouflage and so on now you
would want to discretize each of those
dimensions so this will give you cells
basically so each each of these
discretization will introduce a grid of
cells and what you now do is you want to
keep the best examples of each cell so
if a if you have a creature that's very
fast but not very well camouflaged at
some cell you look at how well it's
doing at the goal that you have in mind
and you want to keep the best one of
those you have a population and
whichever ones are in that cell you keep
the best and then you go ahead and do
kind of change them you could do this
with your evolutionary process like you
can mutate them or it could do it could
be the gradient kind of gradient descent
something so but you mutate them and
they will I guess they will probably end
up in a different cell so you go look at
that cell are these new ones better than
the ones that you remembered from that
old cell and if so replace them kinda
you wanna yeah for each cell keep the
best one and then kind of start continue
developing from those sort of like
Dijkstra's shortest path algorithm and
this will so what it will return is like
an entire landscape of possible
behaviors and for each behavior will
give you the best the best result now it
doesn't mean they all do equally some
will be better some cells will be not as
good in your in with regards to your
cost function but it will give you an
entire landscape and you can could see
then that there are many kind of modes
in this landscape as I said some
creatures are very fast hunters some
camouflage very well so but then they're
kind of slower so you be able to see
these modes in that so that's I found
this pretty pretty interesting and very
kind of opens the door to a lot
different applications so a principle
they employ is what is called goal
switching namely that
means if like a line of development can
benefit from inventions of another line
so let's say the very fast hunters they
they're good at that but then maybe they
they don't reach quite optimal
performance but then another line
develops somewhere else and these are
camouflaged like the camouflaged
life-forms develop so they invent kind
of camouflage now because these the way
this mutation and so on is you can keep
the camouflaged ones around and the
hunters and now the camouflage can kind
of jump over to the hunters it's very
difficult to explain like this but they
call this goal switching and what it
means is that yeah that the hunters can
now adopt a little bit of camouflage
through let's say mutating one of the
camouflaged ones into the hunters or
vice versa and then can kind of benefit
from that invention over there so a good
example of that
they mentioned is that in order to
discover the microwave you first had to
work on radar technology which had
nothing to do with microwaves but
because of the inventions made in radar
technology you could then invent the
microwave easily so it kind of jumped
over into the space of ovens basically
before you only had to make food warm
was just put it in an oven and heat it
up now he had the microwave so that kind
of these algorithms capture the spirit
of this a book they that the the people
who gave the tutorial wrote is why
greatness cannot be planned I'll
definitely get that and I can't
recommend it since I haven't read it yet
but I'm going to get and read it should
be fairly interesting so they give them
a number they gave a number of examples
of this for example robots that can
recover from damage because so they had
a robot with six legs they trained it to
move
now they disabled one leg now usually
you have one solution like you trained
your neural network I don't think it was
even a neural network are you trained
you're like your system to move this
robot as efficiently as possible and now
because you only had one solution one
legs broken it doesn't work anymore but
since you have the entire landscape of
solutions you can easily kind of jump to
other not as good solutions if you have
all legs but you can jump to other
solutions in the solution space and try
them out which ones do still work if I
only now have five legs since you have
the entire landscape you're very well
able to do that so that's pretty cool
the another algorithm tape and it was go
Explorer which is an algorithm that kind
of solved these really hard Atari games
while a while back and what they do in
specific is they kind of have an archive
of states that they have reached in the
past so it's it's a video game and you
do some things and then you are in
certain states so it's an archive of
states and you just pick one of that
right you pick like okay this state it
means I'm like my little person I
control is somewhere over there and then
you just explore from it right you do a
population based you just kind of go
around from it and so on and then you
look at the state you end up in and if
the state you end up in is a known state
like you've been there before so it's
also in your archive then you compare
the two did you get faster to that state
via the new route or did you get faster
to that state via the route that was
already in your archive and if you're
faster in that state via the new route
you will you replace the archived one
with the new one so this again is kind
of like a Dijkstra's shortest path
algorithm extrapolated to this do this
kind of domain where you have to
explore you don't actually have a graph
so I think it's it's pretty cool it's
all kind of the same principle but it
can employ this goal switching thing
right so you go to a certain state but
then all of a sudden because you
explored something else you find a much
quicker way to that state which you
never intended that it happens so this
yeah this is a basic principle that kind
of if you explore a lot then good things
might happen so kind of a serendipity
discovery mechanism and you could use
those good things incorporate them into
the things that already work the last
topic they covered was open-ended search
so a distinction from what they've
already discussed to open-ended is now
they give the example again life on
earth if you consider it it's a single
run of an algorithm it's not that for
every life form a different optimization
was started and kind of started and and
finished optimized for a certain thing
it's all one single run of the same
algorithm and it doesn't really have a
goal in mind so open-ended algorithms
are like that
they kind of define interesting notion
is it still interesting if we were to
just let it run for a billion years like
would it still be interesting if yes
consider it an open-ended algorithm
which I find a really good than the
definition so the the fundamental
property that open-ended algorithms have
and research in this has defined is that
constantly not only is the population
shifting but also the environment is
shifting so there's kind of a never
static situation the environment is
always shifting that also means there's
always new opportunities opening up for
kind of new life on earth for new
creatures to evolve to kind of fill the
niches
that open up and the the research
community around this the open-ended
search open and learning community is is
considering exactly those types of
environments like how can they how can
they even describe those manufacture
those and then learning those so pretty
cool a cool experiment they've shown was
the pig breeder experiment or basically
it's human-in-the-loop so they gave
human humans could cooperate so as a
human you go to a website you you pick
one picture and these pictures are
procedurally generated so they start out
with a very simple pattern and you just
have the opportunity to kind of you pick
one and it gives you a bunch of random
perturbations of the procedurally
generated image and you pick the ones
that you like and then you continue
exploring from there and if you're happy
you can just save that to the database
and someone else can look through the
database and then pick yours for example
to continue and the things that the
humans came up with or that the result
of that was was extremely interesting so
um so not only could you perturb but you
could also kind of mix pictures as far
as I remember not sure anymore but yeah
so but the things they end up with is
yeah you could breed pictures right you
could you could kind of also put
pictures together so the procedural
generation of them and what you end up
with or is remarkable remarkably
interesting things and the point they
made is it's really only from very few
iterations these are like tens or
hundreds of iterations of development
not like a million like we're used to
and there's real tree or phylogenies
that emerge and the crucial lesson they
say is people only find when they are
not looking so if you had a certain goal
in mind you will never be able to you
know change the pictures in the way that
this goal would appear but if you have
no goal in mind you might discover all
kinds of interesting things yeah so that
that is a kind of all I'm going to say
of this they discussed many more things
but I think these are the main takeaways
so population population-based search is
interesting because it can kind of
overcome the problems that if you only
had one optimizer and one optimization
run of one algorithm if you employ
quality diversity in the algorithm map
elites this this enables this kind of
goal switching it gives you back an
entire landscape of IV of learned actors
or systems that for each one you know
it's kind of the best performing one in
that particular constraint of of the of
the dimensions you care about and yeah
open-ended algorithms open-ended search
is definitely a cool research direction
and I encourage you to check it out all
right that was it so far thanks for
listening bye